lots happening in one of Hollywood's
biggest families this is house of cards
guys we have seen in the most recent
episodes of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians the behind the scenes
unfolding of what went down between
Khloe Kardashian Tristan Thompson and
her famous family when it came to light
this cheating scandal of his Sunday we
saw what happened when Khloe gave birth
to their daughter true just after it all
hit the media it was a real tearjerker
here's a clip it's important for me to
stick to my birthday plan because this
is something that I've waited for my
entire life
[Music]
the minute I met my daughter I cannot
believe I'm even saying the words my
daughter I was so in love with her and
she's just perfect that's just it's a
lot harder to filter through stuff when
it's all working then I gave her the
following day this is too much so of
course we saw their Tristan Thompson
even after all of that came to light he
was there for the birth of his daughter
and we had heard that but seeing the
behind the scenes Chloe basically said
look I didn't want to take that moment
from Tristan I didn't want to take it
from our daughter and Tristan and I
could work out what was going on between
us after she was born I also saw him on
Instagram one fan commented and said you
were real mature I would have would have
been a lot worse to him and she said
well you didn't necessarily see on
camera all the things I said so we saw
the mature side of Chloe though and we
have to applaud her on getting through
everything that she got through good for
you Chloe yes we love you other
Kardashian news though for the second
time this month Kourtney Kardashian
having an outing with both her acts
Scott Disick and his girlfriend Sophia
Richie here seen there with Scott yes
she spent some time dining with the two
of them now we know that over the years
despite their ups and downs and on-again
off-again relationship Kourtney and
Scott have always spent time together
for their three kids and stayed close
but this seems to be showing another
step that Kourtney also hanging out with
Sophia Richie and may be showing it's
gotten Sophia are getting pretty serious
they've got a big age gap but they've
been together for a minute now they were
checking out a gallery exhibit in West
Hollywood Kim Kardashian by the way
joining the group inside as well now
they did not pose for photos but the
father of three can be seen standing in
the background of a picture with the two
Kardashian sisters Kourtney and camp
also this is super cute take a look at
little stormy oh there's Kim inside the
event oh yes you see Scott in the
background
excuse me there we go more from inside
hailey cosmetics
Kylie cosmetics bah bah dah you're never
too young to learn brand messaging even
if you're too young to talk that is
adorable little stormy Kylie Jenner and
Travis Scott's young daughter and Kylie
posted that cute video to Instagram of
her half jokingly maybe not jokingly a
teaching stormy how to say Kylie
cosmetics she seems to be doing better
with the word dad
[Music]
[Applause]